portrayed with affable charm by Jorge
Garcia Hurley was the heart and soul of
lost but in his post last fight the
actor has kept a relatively low profile
despite working constantly here's a look
at what he's been up to since bidding
farewell to the island
following his star-making turn on lost
Garcia didn't waste much time booking
his next gigs it should come as no
surprise that those gigs came via his
pal lost co-creator JJ Abrams first up
was a brief but hilariously memorable
turn as a bong wielding security officer
on Abrams underappreciated sci-fi series
fringe you're the best boss I've ever
had Garcia followed that cameo with a
much bigger role on another Abram series
the short-lived crime drama Alcatraz the
show followed a young San Francisco
detective as she tried to unravel the
mystery behind the return of several
long deceased inmates of the infamous
island prison Garcia played dr. Diego
Soto a paranoid conspiracy theorist who
also happens to be an expert on all
things Alcatraz Garcia's comedic chops
have continued to land him roles on
television including a couple of
episodes of one of the biggest sitcoms
of all time How I Met Your Mother he
made his first appearance on the show in
2010 as Steve the Blitz Henry an old
college friend of Marshall and Ted's
much like Hurley the Blitz appears to be
cursed with rotten luck as he got his
nickname because he missed something
amazing every time he left a party early
the episode also makes clever use of
Garcia's lost background by using his
cursed lottery numbers as a phone number
Garcia would reprise the role for
another brief but memorable cameo in the
show's final season when we see that the
blitzes luck hasn't changed all that
much over the years
unlike the Blitz Garcia has had pretty
good luck in his own life as he
continues to book notable supporting
roles on popular TV shows he even went
back to his fantasy roots for ABC's
long-running fairytale drama once upon a
time
Garcia appeared on three episodes of the
show between 2012 and 2013 in a case of
pitch perfect casting he landed the role
of aunt on a magic bean hoarding
surprisingly short giant with a fear of
humans
unfortunately though Garcia didn't share
any screen time with his former lost
co-star Emily de Ravin who was a
once-upon-a-time regular as Belle
Garcia's most surprising cameo came in
2010 when the actors smiling face graced
the cover of Weezer's eighth album the
aptly titled Hurley yes indeed the album
was actually named after Garcia's
beloved lost character as frontman
Rivers Cuomo explained after deciding to
use a photo of Garcia as the cover art
the fans realized that fans would just
refer to it as the Hurley record so it
only made sense to beat them to the
punch
fortunately the album didn't suffer its
name snakes generally rotten luck it
received a warm critical reception and
debuted at number 6 on the Billboard 200
in an even more surprising turn of
events the band even invited Garcia to
come perform live with them on several
tour stops supporting the album and
honestly he wasn't half-bad
Garcia worked hard to make his fans
laugh when he appeared in 2015's the
ridiculous six a Netflix original movie
packed with the likes of Adam Sandler
Rob Schneider and about a dozen or so
other men and women if you've never
heard of ridiculous 6 that's probably
because it wasn't very good in fact it
stands as one of the worst reviewed
films in Adam Sandler's career that
being said
Garcia's turn as the unintelligible herm
was one of the few jokes that actually
worked
although considering the way the movie
was received perhaps he'd rather forget
he was in the movie at all somebody here
could speak her since 2013 Garcia has
portrayed local conspiracy theorists /
consultant Jerry Ortega on CBS's
long-running Hawaii five-o reboot as it
happens it was the idea of a reunion
with his lost co-stars Daniel Dae Kim
and Terry O'Quinn that led Garcia to
take the role the role was initially set
as a 2 episode cameo but Garcia was so
good in the part the producers quickly
promoted him to series regular now he
has no plans on leaving the popular
series anytime soon that's no surprise
considering the perk of shooting on the
island paradise of Oahu which happens to
be where the majority of loss was shot
as well while we're happy that Garcia
has scored some steady work were also a
little worried that he's back on the
island he worked so hard to get away
from